[Musique]
alors avec les fortes chaleurs qui vont
arriver cet été ATIS vous allez nous
proposer quelques conseils pour pouvoir
aider nos compagnons à quatre pattes
durant durant l'été et durant la
canicule notamment effectivement
Mathilde donc vous êtes venus avec un
petit chien un petit chien avec Bounty
qui a été très gentil et de venir
aujourd'hui malgré la canicule pour vous
donner des conseils effectivement même
nous les humains nous avons du mal
à supporter la canicule et pour les
chiens c'est plus difficile puisqu'ils
ont moins de glandes sudoripares pour
transpirer c'est le fait de transpirer
qui nous aide à réguler la température
du corps et les chiens ben transpirent
essentiellement des coussinets et de la
gueule il est très sage Bounty il est
vraiment très très sage alors est-ce que
vous avez justement quelques quelques
conseils pour qu'on puisse les aider au
mieux pour les rafraîchir et oui Bounty
qu'est-ce qu'on fait et ben on sort très
tôt le matin beaucoup plus tôt avant
qu'il fasse très chaud plus tard le soir
Bounty par exemple est sorti hier soir à
21 ça lui évite de d'avoir basho au
coussinet avec le bitume qui est très
chaud vous lui faites de l'ombre à la
maison donc vous baissez les stores s'il
aime le carrelage bah privilégier les
endroits avec le carrelage et puis
changer lui son autre très régulièrement
même si la gamelle est encore remplie
vous privilégiez vous vous remplissez à
chaque fois ce sa gamelle quand vous
sortez bah sortez avec des gourdes avec
de l'eau vous avez des gamelles
transportables vous pouvez facilement
mettre de l'eau à l'intérieur
c'est intéressant ça et quels sont les
justement les risques si son animal a
trop chaud ou pas attraper une
insolation je sais pas les risques c'est
la diarrhée les vomissements donc
l'animal va être fragilisé et vous si
vous avez six risques là vous consultez
très rapidement le vétérinaire ça peut
être très dangereux donc c'est quand
même à apprendre très au sérieux oui et
alors nous on utilise des glaçons pour
se rafraîchir l'été est-ce qu'on peut
aussi utiliser des glaçons pour les
animaux et oui nous pouvons aussi
utiliser des glaçons pour les animaux
déjà le matin quand vous partez au
travail vous pouvez en mettre dans son
eau donc ça gardera son eau au frais et
puis également dans son pâté le pâté
vous pouvez le glacer j'espère que le
pâtissier va être fier de moi j'ai mis
du pâté au congélateur Bounty vraiment
très sage je l'appelle la tentation en
même temps il adore le fromage lui ah
d'accord donc vous avez des techniques
vous avez des petits accessoires vous
pouvez mettre du pâté dans le
congélateur et puis bah votre chien
pourra en manger tranquillement vous
prenez également ce que vous pouvez
faire c'est mettre un gant de toilette
d'abord au niveau des coussinets sous
l'animal et puis ensuite au dessus de sa
tête ce qui est bien donc Bounty lui
n'est pas en surpoids je le dis à chaque
fois c'est pas bon le surpoids pour les
animaux c'est plus eux qui souffrent de
la chaleur également le toilettage vous
n'hésitez pas à le brosser puisque les
poils qui sont en plus ça va donner
encore plus de chaleur
et puis on me pose la question
ventilateur est-ce que c'est bien ou pas
oui vous pouvez mettre le ventilateur
aussi mais il faut pas en abuser le
mettre au bon endroit faut éviter
également le pic de chaleur pour pour
les animaux et puis bah le la baignade
les chiens sont des très bons nageurs
donc faites des sports aquatiques et
puis donnez-lui le tout d'arrosage ça va
créer encore plus un lien de complicité
avec votre chien bon mis à part la
baignade j'ai l'impression que ce sont
quand même des des conseils qu'on peut
reprendre pour pour les chats par
exemple oui c'est presque les mêmes
conseils pour les chats merci beaucoup à
tous barré pour tous ces précieux
conseils j'espère que vous avez bien
pris note autour du plateau et puis chez
vous pour pouvoir aider nos compagnons
pendant les périodes de fortes chaleurs